merci monsieur le Président et ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
Santé et pour vos premières QG monsieur
le ministre des tas de questions à vous
poser qui concernent notre commission
des affaires sociales néanmoins mon
propos concernera les maternités la
semaine passée je me suis rendue à
l'hôpital de La Fontaine à Saint-Denis
en Seine-Saint-Denis où j'ai voulu
rencontrer les équipes de la maternité
et voir comment se préparer l'été il
s'agit d'un établissement de niveau 3
qui fait plus de 4000 accouchements par
an et qui prend en charge notamment des
grossesses à risque et je pense aux
femmes atteintes de drépanocytose le
constat que nous y avons fait accablant
sur 85 femmes 30 manque un tiers nous
avons traversé un service de
néonatologie avec le service des soins
intensifs quasiment vide trois berceaux
sur 20 avec où chacun des mènes pour
essayer de trouver des places pour
envoyer les nouveaux-nés dans des
établissements qui sont à proximité sauf
que aussi sont en situation de tension
vous êtes ministre de la prévention
prévention est complètement laissée de
côté donc ma question est simple que
souhaitez-vous faire pour que les
concernant les maternités les femmes
d'Île-de-France mais partout en France
puissent accoucher en toute sécurité ce
qui n'est pas le cas comment
souhaitez-vous comment pouvez-vous faire
revenir des sages-femmes puisque ce sont
surtout les personnels qui manquent les
sages-femmes dans les hôpitaux et on
nous a signalé que les le recrutement de
sage-femmes à diplôme hors Union
Européenne et beaucoup plus contexte que
celui des praticiens les padus orage
femme et praticien sont des professions
médicales je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre
[Applaudissements]